كان يفترض ان يكون منافس دونالد ترامب
الرئيسيه في السباق الرئاسي المقبل رونج
اراد ان يشبه ترامب في كل شيء محافظ
سياسيا لكن من دون ارث ثقيل في الحكم كان
يمكن للرجل اللاتيني الاصل ان يسحق ترامب
بالضربه القاضيه لكن شيئا حصل في مسيره
ديسانتس لحظته السياسيه تترنح فها هو
ترامب عائد بقوه تحت الاضواء وربما مجددا
الى طريق البيت الابيض في هذه المبارزه مع
ديسانتس
يبدو ترامب رجلا جديدا في اخر مقابلاته
التلفزيونيه فاختار طريقا لم يعهده من قبل
وهو التركيز على السياسات والافكار بدلا
من الاغتيال الكلامي لخصومه
الجديد هذا يربك ديسانس وربما يقصيه بدل
الشتائم المعهوده تحدث ترامب مع فوكس نيوز
عن الاستقلال في مجال الطاقه عن التغيير
المطلوب في برامج التعليم عن مواجهه تدفق
المهاجرين عن تطبيق القانون وعن الامل
والسلامه في المدن
وبينما يكسب ترامب النقاط في الاعلام يخسر
ديسانس نقاطه على الجانب الاخر ترامب يصعد
دون توقف في الاستطلاعات متقدما بنحو
اربعين نقطه عن منافسه اللدود ديسانتس
الذي باته والذي يحمل على الدعايه السلبيه
التي يتعرض لها من قبل الاعلام نيويورك
تايمز مثلا تناولت استخدام حاكم فلوريدا
لطائرات خاصه في تنقلاته بينما قالت
جورنال ان ديسانتس يتجنب الحديث عن قصته
الخاصه مجله تايمز وصلت الى حد الحديث عن
عدائيه مفترضه لدى المرشح الجمهوري مذكره
بانه اطلق شعارا للمطالبه بوضع اشهر اطباء
امريكا انتم بفوتي في السجن اثناء جائحه
كورونا
واكثر من ذلك كله نعت ديسانتس بشكل متكرر
منافسه ترامب بالمحتال قد يكون ديسانتس
تبنى الفكره القائله ان قياده معسكر
الجمهوريين تتطلب قدرا من التنمر والهجوم
السياسي لكن تلك الوصفه القاسيه ورغم انها
نجحت مع ترامب الا انها لا تبدو نافعه مع
ديسنتس
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات